en el vídeo anterior vimos lo que sucede
cuando tenemos resistencias en serie
ahora vamos a ver qué sucede cuando
tenemos resistencias en paralelo
tomamos un color vibrante magenta y en
esta ocasión voy a dibujar mi circuito
más o menos así donde aquí tengo mi
batería con la terminal positiva la
terminal negativa mi conductor perfecto
pero aquí voy a tener dos resistencias
en paralelo voy a tener una bifurcación
aquí tengo una resistencia
y aquí tengo otro camino con otra
resistencia y se unen en este otro punto
vamos a llamar esta resistencia 1 y esta
resistencia 2 y también indicamos la
poco intuitiva convención de que la
corriente va en este sentido
aunque nosotros sabemos que en realidad
va en sentido contrario quiero seguir
insistiendo en esto porque me parece
importante comprender lo que está
ocurriendo en la realidad de que aquí
tenemos los electrones y son los
electrones los que se mueven por el
circuito de la terminal negativa hacia
la terminal positiva
en el vídeo anterior vimos que al tener
dispositivos o componentes en serie la
corriente en todo el circuito es
constante pero ahora pensemos qué es lo
que está ocurriendo aquí
veámoslo desde el punto de vista de los
electrones que van a fluir con cierta
tasa o cierta velocidad y van a llegar a
esta bifurcación aquí van a tener que
elegir por dónde se van a ir algunos
irán por este camino de arriba otros se
irán por este camino de abajo
si pensamos en ello veremos que el flujo
de electrones en esta rama de arriba más
el flujo de electrones en esta otra rama
de abajo tendrán que igualar al flujo de
electrones en esta parte de nuestro
conductor perfecto y después se
regresarán al mismo camino en este lado
si lo pensamos de esta manera y aquí
retomamos la convención de que está aquí
va nuestra corriente y esta corriente
lo llamamos
tenemos a los electrones que se mueven a
cierta velocidad llegarán a la
bifurcación y dependiendo de las
resistencias algunos electrones se irán
por arriba otros por abajo si las
resistencias fueran iguales y seguimos
usando la convención de que digamos que
la falta de electrones va en este
sentido y fluye de igual manera en ambas
ramas siempre y cuando las resistencias
sean iguales la corriente se va a
dividir en la bifurcación ya que se
pasan por aquí pasa por acá y acá se
vuelven a unir por lo que la corriente
en este lado de acá también va a ser la
flecha
no mejor la dibujó bonita la corriente
que pasa en esta parte del circuito
también va a ser uno
pero veamos cuál es el valor de las
corrientes que se bifurcan vamos a
nombrar a la corriente que pasa por acá
y por acá como idos
y 2 y la corriente que se va por acá
y por acá como ib3
3 podemos podemos imaginar esto como si
fueran tuberías que la corriente llega a
esta bifurcación esta corriente y uno
llega a la bifurcación y es igual a la
corriente que sale de esta bifurcación
que es igual a 2
+ y 3
pueden imaginarse que si 2
es igual a 5 colom sobre segundo y 3 es
igual a 6 colom sobre segundo en un
segundo dado aquí donde se unen ambas
tendremos 5 colores que vienen de esta
rama 6 colores que vienen de esta otra y
entonces tendremos 11 cool oms
por segundo aquí tendremos 11 cool oms
por segundo cuando ambas corrientes se
mezcla espero que esto les ayude a
entender que esta corriente de acá es la
combinación de estas dos corrientes
ahora que otras cosas sabemos
sabemos que el voltaje a través de este
conductor ideal es constante vamos a
dibujarlo en otro color
el voltaje a todo lo largo de lo que
estoy dibujando aquí
en este lado d
nuestro conductor perfecto
podemos ver esta parte morada como una
extensión de la terminal positiva y de
manera similar pero ahora voy a elegir
otro color
esta parte de acá que estoy poniendo en
podemos considerarla como una extensión
de la terminal negativa así que la
diferencia de voltaje entre estas dos
terminales la llamamos voltaje de que es
el voltaje entre este punto y este otro
y es el mismo que el voltaje que está en
el extremo de r2 en estos extremos y
entre el extremo de r1
que a su vez es el mismo voltaje que se
encuentra en esos extremos de acá
entonces cuál será la corriente total
del sistema podemos imaginar esta
bifurcación como una caja negra como una
caja negra todo esto
con una sola resistencia combinada por
lo que la corriente total del sistema
será aplicando la ley de ohm voltaje
entre la resistencia total y esto es
igual a la corriente que va a pasar por
r 1 vuelva a ser esta corriente 1 que
está pasando por aquí
será el voltaje que pasa por este
registro dividido entre la resistencia
eso es lo que nos dice la ley de ohm la
escribimos nuevamente acá la ley de ohm
es voltaje igual la resistencia por
corriente o recordando nuestro mnemonic
o victoria es la reina de inglaterra
despejamos la corriente que es lo que
nos interesa y nos queda que la
corriente es igual al voltaje entre la
resistencia ya hemos dicho que el
voltaje que pasa por aquí es el mismo en
todo el circuito así que nuestro voltaje
entre resistencia total va a ser igual
este voltaje entre la resistencia uno
más y lo mismo aplica aquí para la
resistencia 2 el voltaje que pasa por r
2 que es el mismo voltaje en todo el
circuito dividido entre el valor de esta
resistencia así que va a ser igual a b /
r
2 todas estas veces son iguales por lo
que podemos eliminar las de aquí o
dividir todo entre voltaje y nos va a
quedar
que uno entre la resistencia total es
igual a uno entre resistencia uno más
uno entre resistencia 2
y ustedes pueden decir bueno si tenemos
aquí una tercera resistencia en paralelo
o una tercera rama pues igual aquí
agregaremos un término más uno entre r
tres o si tuviéramos cuatro resistencias
en paralelos 5 6 n agregaríamos tantos
términos uno entre el valor de la
resistencia como ramas con resistencias
tengamos acá ahora veamos si podemos
usar esta información para resolver un
problema y normalmente es más fácil
resolver un problema que explicar todos
los conceptos que están detrás de éste
de hecho la mayoría de los problemas de
circuitos se usan matemáticas muy
básicas vamos a despejar esta pantalla
aquí tengo una batería
más menos de
16 volts
solo para afirmar que aunque es
recomendable dibujar ordenadamente el
circuito yo si quiero lo puedo dibujar
así
más o menos algo aquí hay una
resistencia que hace algo extraño por
acá aquí está el conductor aquí otra
resistencia que se une con esta otra acá
y cierro mi circuito
esta cosa extraña que he dibujado y que
jamás verán en ningún libro de texto es
topo lógicamente el mismo circuito que
dibujé anteriormente aunque ahora le voy
a agregar números digamos que esta
resistencia aquí a la izquierda es de
2011 2011 y la resistencia que se
encuentra aquí es de 511
lo que quiero saber es cuál es la
corriente que circula por todo este
sistema
más o menos dibujamos la corriente por
acá siguiendo nuestra convención
lo primero es encontrar cuál es la
resistencia equivalente y luego usar la
ley de ohm para calcular la corriente
como encontramos la resistencia
equivalente bueno acabamos de mostrar
que 1 entre la resistencia total es
igual a en este caso 1 entre la
resistencia de 2011
+ 1 entre esta otra resistencia que es
de 5 años
vamos a hacer una suma de fracciones
espero que recuerden cómo hacerla
1 / rt es igual tenemos este término
común denominador 20
uno más un quinto para que esté en
términos de 20 a vos son 420 amos es que
es 14 tenemos 520 a vos que es lo mismo
que un cuarto 5 por unas 55 por 420 esto
es equivalente por lo tanto nuestra
resistencia total va a ser igual a 4 oms
así que podemos dibujar este circuito
loco como algo así podemos dibujar este
circuito aquí muy bonito con esta
resistencia su batería
que es de 16 volts positivo o negativo
esta resistencia es de 42
ya que todo esto combinado
sólo 4 oms
si tenemos una diferencia de potencial
aquí de 16 volts la corriente va por acá
dibujamos de nuevo la corriente
siguiendo la convención la corriente va
hacia acá
y nuestra resistencia es de 4 ohms cuál
va a ser la corriente bueno ya quedamos
que el voltaje es igual a la resistencia
por la corriente
sustituimos valores nuestro voltaje es
de 16 volts esto es igual a la
resistencia de 4 por nuestra corriente
despejamos la corriente nos queda que es
16 entre 4 que a su vez es igual a 44
amperes
ahora hagamos algo interesante
encontremos cuál es el valor de la
corriente que pasa por estas
resistencias vamos a llamar a la
corriente que pasa por acá y 1 y a la
que pasa por acá y 2
sabemos que la diferencia de potencial
en la resistencia es también de 16 volts
así que tenemos
nuestra corriente 1 tenemos que el
voltaje de 16 /
la resistencia de 20 va a ser igual a 4
quintos
amperes y de manera similar nuestra
corriente 2 va a ser igual a 16 entre 5
que es igual a 3 y un quinto de amper
así que la mayor parte de la corriente
va a circular por acá ya que suena
lógico porque esta resistencia es más
pequeña no va a ver tantos obstáculos
aquí
entonces nuestra corriente 1 es igual
0.8 amperes nuestra corriente 2 es igual
a 3.2 amperes esta corriente es mayor
que ésta y también tiene sentido que
cuando sumamos a ambas corrientes 3.2
más punto 8 nos da el total de la
corriente que se encuentra aquí una vez
que se han mezclado ambas que nuestra
corriente fue de 4 amperes aquí a la
salida de cualquier manera espero que
esto les haya dado un mejor
entendimiento de lo que sucede cuando
ponemos resistencias en paralelo y nos
veremos en el siguiente vídeo